[Music]
Oh
joy de nalani has rediscovered her
lighter side she put six years of work
into her fourth studio album Kleist
Hayek writing and discarding song after
song the title is a tribute to a Berlin
subway station you know I was sitting in
the subway and I came out of the tunnel
and into the light somehow it was a good
moment I stood there right in front of a
sign saying gly strike and then I
thought that's it from the navigator
thurs a sister the subway station in
Berlin's kreuzberg district was central
to Joy dennell on his childhood she grew
up close by now as an adult she's going
back to her roots
[Music]
glass by the slice strike is a metaphor
for one it's the place where I grew up
that's very real to me but it's also a
metaphor for a place where you can
change lines it's a center in the middle
and from there you can set off into life
but there's always the possibility of
returning or staying away it stands for
the way life itself goes dengi began and
ina Owens in only five will come here
Zack see nicest nick muir dr. sustain so
how's ur home is an important topic for
this Berliner with South African roots
she puts a personal spin on political
hot button issues let's niyati chasm
last year the general mood started to
shift off and radically and some people
felt free to say these racist things i
took this feeling into the session and
talked about it and started thinking
about my home what does it really mean
tonight reminds well holes are you
though where can I feel at home and
where I can't joy 10 alani was born in
1973 her father came from South Africa
and her mother from Heidelberg joy
decided to become a musician as a little
girl she made her breakthrough in 1999
performing a duet with rapper max haha
the two became a couple both on and off
stage musically they're on the same
wavelength three years later they put
out their debut album mamani it's made
130,000 sales to date joy den Alana's
sound is a blend of R&B and African
music it's been allotted Africa I went
to South Africa and asked people there
about my family's past I think it can
change your life when you know all about
your past kind of a money buddy for gang
herbicide was they've been turning out
one top 10 album after another among
them Maureen in 2011
[Music]
annoying honokaa
[Music]
this is the sound of joy de nalani in
2017 she has a distinct Berlin soul
sound and sings about love fizzling out
is this an album takes stock of the last
few years it deals with topics I always
wanted to work through along with very
specific current issues as well in
essence it's like a review of a panorama
of joy cuz panorama fondren after nearly
two decades in the music business she
seems to have defined her own sound joy
den alani the soul queen of gly strike
you